[Música]
26 de octubre del 2014 el domingo hay
una competencia de baile en la tarde
estoy muy feliz muy estresada pero a
final de cuentas feliz ese mismo día me
han invitado unos amigos por un café ya
estaba en cuarto semestre de prepa y ya
sabía que iba a estudiar derecho estamos
viendo la posibilidad de ir a una
competencia de derechos humanos en la
ciudad de mexico ya me sentía como todo
un adulto saliendo de mi zona de confort
haciendo cosas diferentes voy lo voy a
afrontar a mi mamá para que me dé
permiso está destinado despidiéndose de
mi hermano no me hace caso le vuelvo a
preguntar y me dice que no
porque mi mamá me tiene que decir que no
a todo
marsé es que domingo aparte de hyères a
lista y estoy un poquito cansada no me
siento bien mejor déjalo para la próxima
obviamente me enojo con ella y cuando
meten el desayuno ni las gracias le doy
comemos en silencio me dice que me cruce
con mi abuela y que regrese más tarde
paralizarme para la competencia de baile
me levanto muy indignada salgo y al
salir meto un portazo ya cruzando me
casé mi abuela que está enfrente
claro que me entra el sentimiento y digo
la verdad es que hice un berrinche
innecesario
ahorita llegando le pido perdón
al estar con mi abuela empiezo a
sentirme muy rara muy triste muy
angustiada entonces decido volver a mi
casa y al momento en el que regreso a la
casa
abro la puerta y lo primero que veo es a
mi mamá tirada en el piso con la cara
morada ojos de pánico tratando de
decirme algo
al acercarme lo entiendo ayuda
agarró su celular y trató de marcar un
número de emergencia pero tiene cortada
la línea el de la casa está igual es en
serio salvo gritando a la calle pidiendo
ayuda y me escuchan mi abuela y mina no
hagan a las ambulancias no hay ninguna
disponible no lo podía creer
le pedimos ayuda a los vecinos para que
nos ayuden a subirla a la camioneta
pero todos están muy tranquilos creo que
soy la única que entiende que mi mamá no
está bien
manejamos a la cruz roja que está como
un minuto de la casa y en el camino le
tomo la mano
y le digo mamá
eres una luchadora quédate conmigo te
amo
dejando tanto al llegar a la cruz roja
me bajo y me doy cuenta que nadie está
haciendo nada y les digo a gritos que
por favor que mi mamá no está bien y
tardan más del tiempo necesario por
actuar ya cuando al fin la mete en un
cuartito veo que un doctor entra con
ella para esto ya está toda mi familia
ahí
al momento en el que sale el doctor
veo que mueve la cabeza de un lado a
otro
en el momento en lo que sé
qué significa eso mi mundo se paraliza
entro en estado de negación
mi mamá murió
pero como pipas como por qué
vea mi hermano los ojos dice que piensa
lo mismo que yo que vamos a hacer
tiempo después me explicaron que mi mamá
sufre un émbolo pulmonar que es cuando
un coágulo se va a una arteria del
pulmón y te ocasiona un paro
respiratorio es una emergencia médica
letal que no se puede detectar con un
chequeo común
mi mamá era mi mejor amiga mi compañera
en todo mi hombro para llorar mi heroína
mi motor de vida sin ella yo me sentía
perdida sin rumbo recuerdo que solía
decirme macho qué pasa si un día me
muero y yo rapidísimo le contestaba yo
me voy contigo sin duda y cuando llegó
ese día ese maldito día ella ya se había
ido y yo seguí aquí
gracias a lo que pasó supe lo que era
tener el corazón de estos dos millones
de pedazos lo que era llorar tanto que
piensas que no vas a preparar el querer
dormir por días a darte cuenta en la
realidad la que estás metida
si prefería dormir
a sentir ese dolor que me estaba matando
ese dolor que no le deseas ni a tu peor
enemigo
no podía sacarme ese día la cabeza la
recordaba en todo momento y en todo
lugar
- con mi abuela con mi hermano con los
vecinos con los de la cruz roja
inclusive me enojé con ella por habernos
dejado a mi hermano ya mí
pero me di cuenta quién es el verdadero
culpable mi dolor nada más y nada menos
que la muerte
la sentía en cada célula de mi ser a
cada paso que daba y me di cuenta que yo
tener que tratar con este villano por el
resto de mi vida
pero ha pasado el tiempo y me ha
enseñado cosas he aprendido de ella por
lo cual ha pasado de ser un villano a
ser nuestro
quisiera compartirles las lecciones que
yo aprendí si mi mamá
la primera es que llega sin advertencias
y sin despedidas no importa si la
persona que se fue lo hizo una forma
repentina o con una enfermedad que
conlleva mucho tiempo uno nunca va a
estar preparado para algo así siempre
vamos a querer más tiempo para
despedirnos bien de esa persona para
asimilar mejor las cosas para aprovechar
al máximo pero la realidad es que
cualquier situación que te presenta la
vida nunca vas a estar 100% preparado
entonces tenemos que aceptar y dejar ir
la segunda es que la vida es demasiado
corta para despertar con remordimientos
cada momento estaba pensando en
cualquier minúsculo detalle en el cual
yo no había sido una buena hija o me
tortura a mí misma diciendo que no
estaba haciendo lo necesario para hacer
la mujer de la cual ella estaría
orgullosa pero lo que no me podía sacar
de la cabeza y que no me dejaba dormir
es que la última vez que yo estuve con
mi mamá fue estando peleadas
porque tenía que ser una adolescente
nefasta la última vez que vi a mi mamá
bien
ese recuerdo me atormenta por mucho
tiempo hasta que viendo su computadora
fija encontré unas fotografías que me
hicieron recordar cosas muy bonitas la
primera estamos en liverpool comprando
un regalo para una piñata y llegó y me
puso las orejitas de mini mouse y empezó
a tomarme fotos como una fotógrafo
profesional y estaba rojísima de que
mamá qué estás haciendo y me dijo que tú
siempre vas a hacer mi niña
y la segunda mi mamá era muy aprensivo
para dejarme manejar entonces cuando mi
tío me prestó ese monstruo mi mamá
estaba nerviosísima pero claro que
cuando llegue sana y salva la casa
empezó a llorar y empezó a también
tomarme fotos que porque ya era toda una
señorita grande
estas cosas simples que aparezcan es
algo que yo comparto con mi mamá algo
muy especial y ahí es cuando me di
cuenta que no sirve de nada estar
pegándonos en el pecho diciendo que por
qué no pasaron o porque no hicimos las
cosas de determinada forma sino recordar
que así como tuvo adoraba a esa persona
ella te adoraba con la misma intensidad
haya pasado lo que haya pasado
la tercera es que no necesitas tener
todo resuelto para salir adelante
créanme que es extremadamente
desgastante e innecesario el estar
tratando resuelve el misterio de la vida
que le pasó a esa persona porque se fue
verdaderamente existe una vida después
de la muerte hay que entender que no
tenemos las respuestas para todas las
preguntas que nos hacemos
hay que dejar de estresar nos sobre
pensar las cosas de ver el futuro a ver
qué va a pasar porque miren las cosas
van a pasar las tengamos previstas
la cuarta es que hasta el paso más
pequeño significa
el tercer día de camino me había
fallecido mi familia pensó que era buena
idea que ya volviéramos a la escuela mi
hermano y yo entonces llegué a la
primera clase tranquila normal sin
querer ser notada y al entrar al salón
llega un amigo que con la imprudencia de
frente ya que me dice lo siento mucho
por tu perdida
y yo así es en serio yo escuchando eso
una semana es lo último que quería que
alguien me dijera
pero deje que eso cambiara mi estado de
ánimo y se prende con mis amigos ponen
atención en clase
poniéndome al corriente y aunque en este
momento yo no me diera cuenta ahora que
me pongo analizarlo esa final de cuenta
fue avance
por más pequeño que se haya visto
cometemos el error de pensar que como
una vida ningún cambio drástico en esta
vida las cosas nunca van a mejorar pero
se nos olvidan esos pequeños detallitos
que aunque nos parezcan muy simples nos
han hecho personas más maduras más
fuertes y más comprensivas con los demás
y sobre todo con nosotros mismos
la quinta es permítete ayudar por los
demás aunque creas que no te entienden
no sé ustedes pero yo cuando me sentía
muy triste preferí irme solo a llorar
que nadie me molestará porque porque yo
sé que mi familia y mis amigos me tratan
de ayudar pero como no entienden mi
situación mucho menos y van a entender
mi tristeza y claro uno trate de ser
empático pero no es lo mismo imaginarte
las cosas a vivirlas en carne y hueso
mis mejores amigas se dieron cuenta de
esto y me hicieron cosas bellísimas para
hacerme sentir mejor
me compraron un oso de peluche entre
todos esos grandotes para que cada vez
que yo estuviera triste lo abrazara me
llenaron de cartas y no me saber que yo
nunca iba a estar sola inclusive se
levantaron una vez a las 7 de la mañana
a hacerme desayuno porque mi mamá tiene
una tradición de ser hot cakes en
domingo
cuando una persona se va
nunca vas a poder llenar ese hueco que
dejó
la gente es única y reemplazable pero sí
creo
que hay personas que llegan por una
determinada razón a tu vida porque
aunque sean personas diferentes con
historias muy diferentes a las tuyas a
final de cuentas te enriquecen como ser
humano y al momento en el que empiezas a
unir puntos y entrelazar los momentos
que has pasado te das cuenta que ese
plan que está diseñado específicamente
para ti que aún no logras comprender del
todo por alguna razón estás en el lugar
correcto con las personas correctas
ahora tampoco se vale querer darle todo
el peso a una persona ellos también
tienen sus problemas y aunque se
ofrezcan no siempre vas a escuchar lo
que quieres hay que recordar que hay
personas que se dedican especial
especialmente a escucharte y ayudarte a
solucionar esos problemas pero estamos
muy orgullosos para buscar ayuda
profesional y créanme que ayuda no sean
testarudos y vayan a buscarlas van a ver
que van a cambiar su punto de vista
totalmente
las 6 es que aprende a ver esa persona
en los detalles más sencillos que te
ofrece la vida
el día del funeral de mi mamá antes de
pasarme a la misa
en la sala de velación y yo ya cansa de
llorar le hable a mamá por favor hazme
saber que estás bien claro que no obtuve
respuesta hablada pero al momento que yo
vi el cielo el atardecer más bonito que
había visto en mi vida era azul con
naranja y las nueces las nubes en
pedacitos y se veía algo así
la vida no acaba se transforma
yo sé que es difícil que ya no voy a
poder ver a mi mamá despertándome a las
5 de la mañana el domingo para que
vayamos a pasear a las perritas porque
el día está bellísimo y no hay ningún
momento que perder también es difícil
darme cuenta que yo ya no voy a poder
acostarme con ella y abrazarla y
sentirme segura y sentirme plena pero si
hay algo que yo aprendí en este evento
que me cambio de por vida es que hay que
aprender a ver esas personas en esos
pequeños detalles que te ofrece la vida
para volver ese momento en algo hermoso
vela en la sonrisa de un niño belenes de
atardecer belenes o que te haga reír que
hace que te duele la panza y nunca te
vas a sentir solo
las siete es que nos justifique es lo
que pasó para hacer cosas increíbles en
sexto semestre de prepa me empecé a
portar muy mal y estaba descuidando
mucho mi escuela porque siempre decía a
mí no es que es la hora de llorar
entonces no voy a hacer nada no voy a
estudiar no voy a hacer proyectos porque
pues es que mi mamá sí murió no no no
puedo hacer nada
obviamente me di cuenta que eso no se
vale ahora yo no digo que no puedan
llorar al contrario es necesario para el
proceso de sanación pero al momento en
el que deje de llorar no se te olvide
que te tienes que levantar pase lo que
pase
la 8 es vive como si no hubiera un
mañana
no dejes de ser esa persona que eras
antes
antes de que te pasara esa cosa que
empezó a apagar tu brillo no te pierdas
a ti mismo piensa en algo que te encanta
así
que te acelera el corazón que le
platicas mil veces a todos tus amigos y
no te canso de decirlo por más que te
digan que ya lo han escuchado
ahora que lo sabes
ve y hazlo
no te detengas no lo pienses porque por
más cliché que yo pueda cenar la vida es
extremadamente corta y se va en un abrir
y cerrar de ojos
mi mamá solía decirme h qué pasa si un
día yo me muero y yo le contestaba yo me
voy contigo sin duda nunca les dije lo
que ella me contestaba a mí un poco
enojada me decía no chiquita tú sigues
adelante
en ese momento ella y yo no nos dimos
cuenta
pero estas palabras están destinadas
para hoy para este momento
hazlo por ti
hazlo por ella
y mientras lo hagas recuerda que las
personas nunca mueren
si las llevas en el corazón
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]